the gigantic US Navy ship comfort enters
New York about to dock at the terminal
normally reserved for cruise ships a 275
meter long floating hospital with more
than 700 hospital beds 12 operating
rooms and 1,200 doctors nurses and staff
New York hospitals will start sending
sick patients not infected with
coronavirus to the ship this week to
free up hospital beds for those who do
have the virus some New Yorkers came out
of their apartments where most have been
holed up for more than two weeks to
marvel at the ship a memorial to the
victims of the 9/11 terrorist attacks
looks over the Hudson River the last
time the comfort was in New York Harbor
was three days after 9/11 to help those
injured let me be clear that this is
such a crucial part of the plan we are
putting in place but I want you to
understand the sheer magnitude of the
plan we need to triple our hospital bed
capacity in New York City by May
but the comfort alone won't be enough to
fill the surge of the sick New York is
also having to look elsewhere this is
Central Park in New York City and on any
normal day you would probably see people
out there on the grass enjoying
themselves but this is not a normal day
and these are no normal times right now
what's being built behind me is an
emergency tent hospital and when it's
completed it will have about 70 beds for
people that are sick and in need of help
when did you ever think you would see
this being built in Central Park New
York has over 9,000 sick people in
hospitals with coronavirus tens of
thousands of more hospital beds will be
needed time is of the essence the worst
isn't supposed to hit for another two
weeks
Gabe Rose Ando al Jazeera New York